our phone number is six one seven eight
three zero
4750 let's go to our next caller from
the nine one six area code caller what's
your name and where are you calling from
hi my name is Valerie I'm calling from
Sacramento California
great what's on your mind I was calling
in regards to your question you're
asking it sort of what our take was on
Melania and her frown from Donald's look
yes just before you before you comment
for people who may not know what you're
talking about earlier in the week we
covered a story where there's this
moment where Donald Trump during the
inauguration turns to Melania Trump he
says something and then she has a look
that I described and many other women
who side agreed is a look of fear in
fact and that was sort of the general
gist of it and the clip that the story
just exploded on YouTube hundreds of
thousands of views so for people who
don't know what we're talking about
that's what we're talking about and yes
what's your comment or question about it
well I was thinking about the deposition
of Ivana that she gave when she was
divorcing Donald Trump and under oath
she swore that he raped her in 1989 and
that it came off of him being upset with
her and so what was really weird to me
was the way you were saying that you
thought of it is something that gave her
a look he said something I thought it
was like a warning like something's
coming it was such a weird smile he did
too and he turned away from her like you
know he's anticipating something he's
going to do and so that's kind of what
it made me think of and and I saw that
fear too yeah I mean basically what
you're pointing to by reference and a
bunch of people who emailed me about the
whole Ivana saying from 89 or I believe
it was 89 which is nothing here 89 is
definitely there's nothing here that
creates a different narrative about
Trump we have more than a dozen women
who accused him of sexual assault we
have him on you know on audio recording
saying sometimes you just have to grab
women by the [ __ ] and take what what
you want because you're famous and blah
blah blah we have a comment made under
oath by one of his ex-wives about the
that he raped her force forcibly had sex
with her so the things from the
inauguration it doesn't paint a
different picture it all sort of to me
and I don't know if you would disagree
it paints a very consistent picture of
Trump it doesn't and the other thing to
think about is that so the deposition
happened in 1990 she's granted a divorce
and she's granted a divorce on the
grounds of cool and inhuman treatment by
Donald Trump so and the fact that he
actually bit the cyst during a lot of
the questions being asked of him during
the deposition I find very telling as
well yeah oh yeah yeah
no you're right I mean I began our favor
there's much more than only what we
mentioned in that story and a lot of
people but men and women have been
writing in about it and I appreciate you
giving me your feedback about that and
really thanks for the call great to hear
from Sacramento always thank you take
care all right great a very interesting
a lot of people commenting about that